At this point in the class, you've gotten a good idea of how jQuery works works.
You've used the three main types of selectors, and
you've started navigating around the DOM with traversal methods.
That's awesome.
But now it's time to start making changes to the DOM,
which is the whole purpose of jQuery.
To that end, you'll be using the jQuery API documentation in the next lesson.
And rather than going through each method one by one, I will be walking you
through a series of challenges where you'll be asked to take apart
the jQuery documentation to figure out how to make changes to a sample page.
To get started, I want to walk you through the general format of
the jQuery API documentation.